water a living thing the diving bears as
things it's hungry territorial but
there's nothing to fear no need to
resist you just go with it
carve out an opening with your fingers
and slide your body through this play
your arms out kick your feet propel
forward with everything you've thought
look at him
nobody's more in their element than he
is right now hmm like a dolphin
who's that
three mutts woke he transferred to our
class last week
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the fastest one in the water Haruka
and I stop okay seriously when are you
gonna stop calling me that already
Wow watching you spin was so cool
someday I'll be able to swim just like
you they weren't lyin you're fast
what's your time I don't know what I
don't care well at least you're living
up to your reputation
hey let me ask you something
do you want to enter a relay with me at
the next tournament I swing free or
don't swim at all really whoo it's time
for that kind of thing
all I'm interested in is feeling the
water
the ice with heart to never doubt the
sensation never doubt myself nor resist
9 me and the water
oh one well what was I thinking I was
just a kid what did I know grandma used
to say youth is wasted on the young
at 10 you're a prodigy 15 a genius by
the time 20 rolls around you normal if
that's true I've got three years till
I'm just normal the way I see it normal
can't get here fast enough
[Music]
[Music]
George and I got you wet though
where you want them bunch of I chose up
a boys wolf official bear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning miss Tamara oh good morning
Mikoto
oh wait here take this Wow thank you
have a good one
you too Mikoto
[Music]
hey there
[Music]
why am I not surprised
hey it's me coming in now not even
dressed yet
good morning Haruka I thought we agreed
not to call me that
[Music]
don't tell me you bathed in that thing
again yeah yeah I'm gonna be late for
school isn't that supposed to be my life
you say we're gonna be late what you're
doing this now well I haven't had
breakfast yet
yeah but you're wearing an apron over
your swimsuit aren't you cold
no I just don't want to get oil on my
swimsuit macro on toast today huh so any
particular reason you came to get me
well yeah you didn't show up for the
assembly yesterday felt like calling in
sick it was only the first day of school
though
why don't I fill you in on the details
then we're in the same class again the
woman teaching homeroom is new this year
I think has a BA in classic Lin nice but
a little air it expects us to get all
these old refa needs to warm up a zone
so I can swim in the ocean like now I
sure hope it gets warmer soon then you
can swim again
mr. Junichi tato Koro here miss calorie
Tessa pop here let's see this Huracan
Donna say this happens every time I'm
used to it excuse me miss harp is a guy
so you are very sorry mr. Nonna's a
great leave you're here yesterday
correct I've already introduced myself
to your classmates of course but anyhow
my name is Miss omekata hey bear I think
she's a local girl went to college in
Tokyo Dome oh yeah landed her dream job
right out of the gate but wanna go
getting sacrificed amazing who knows
what was your dream job maybe something
to do with music
great how are we supposed to learn from
a washed-up performer who got into
education as a plan-b
I'm gonna go home now lunchtime what do
you think should we go eat on the roof
sure whatever you say bring my lunch go
buy something in the cafeteria or we
could share mine if you want you like
squid it's been a long time huh guess
you finally made it hey he just called
me Haruka wait not Issa we haven't seen
you in forever
but since the Swim Club shut down how
many years ago what's that now a few I
went to a different school back then so
the pool was the only place we hung out
whoa cherry blossoms they had fancy
landscaping like this around the pool
where you went to middle school didn't
they Erika please stop calling me by
that name isn't that you're actually the
cherry blossoms are nice touch but the
pool never gets used here there's no
swim team that kind of sucks where do
you guys swim these days I don't not
competitively what's the hell
you're kidding right do you know how
long I've been looking forward to
enrolling and he will Toby so we could
race together I don't know what to tell
you naughty sad things change we're not
kids anymore
well Haru is still swimming just not
competitively trust me he needs water
like we need air when it's summer you
can always find him in the ocean unless
it's this morning where I found him in
the back don't get it those aren't even
the same thing just sounds like he's
into bathing hey we could start a hot
springs Club give me in a nap right
please I can't stand the heat I guess I
hasn't changed hey you guys have heard
about our old swimming club right they
lost the lease or something and they're
gonna tear it down soon so I was
thinking we should stop by before they
do for old times sake we have to go dig
that up don't we exactly it's already
closed but we could sneak in under the
cover of darkness you have fun with that
count me out don't be like that Haru
please come with us I don't want to go
you don't think it'll be fun not even a
little I think you should come just a
humor give me one good reason
we'd have full access to an indoor pool
a pool that happens to be much bigger
than a bathtub this place is so nice how
long have you been living here by
yourself whose mom didn't want him to
have to change schools when his dad
moved for work
mackerel again no one's forcing you to
eat well looks delicious I remember you
used to eat this stuff all the time so
uh are you sure about this whole thing
what you weren't on board a little while
ago don't chicken out now I'm not all
I'm trying to say is that it seems sort
of wrong it's only the three of us what
else are we supposed to do
I mean reinstall the way in another
country
[Music]
so I won't be going to middle school
here what do you mean why not I'll be in
Australia that's a different country for
I'm gonna go somewhere with a good swim
team so why cuz I want to compete in the
Olympics why are you only telling us now
what about the relay I'm still here for
that I don't leave until the day after
the tournament it'll be the last time we
swim together so let's make it count
you swim free alright don't swim it all
you can swim free in the relay with me
please non SI this is our last shot come
on alright listen I'll make you a
promise
swim with me and you'll see something
you'll never forget
wow this place really is trashed
sopia he prepared purifying salt soft
coz some people say this place is
haunted please don't scare me like that
you think I'm lying people see shadows
creeping around here at me Makoto this
girl I know said she even heard sobbing
this will protect us from evil spirits
and stuff don't want one of them
following you home
[Music]
do you feel something Nagisa
since when does sugar ward off ghosts
salt sugar it's all the same right
anything has magical properties if you
believe hard enough
mind over matter that's the secret yeah
sure
same deal with ghosts they're all in
your head people see what they wanna see
just my foot hitting a cannon ah geez
you're doing this on purpose we can't
help but if you're scared of your own
shadow
helping it all now sorry I was just
kidding whoa memories huh it's not
nearly as trashed on the inside look at
this it's the old lounge guys over here
hurry
these take you back look this is from
when we won the relay remember
[Music]
swim with me and you'll see something
you'll never forget
[Music]
before of us earn this together so it
doesn't make sense for us to take turns
keeping it at our homes no we'll bury it
in a time capsule and then we'll dig it
up when we're all grown up
what can I say I'm a romantic her oh
come on sorry
I think the marker will still be there
after all these years I think maybe we
can pick up the pace a little bit what
are the chances I didn't think I'd run
into you guys what are you doing back
here though don't you get it they'd
bought the four of us back together oh
we all have to be here it exactly the
same time tomorrow seriously still
hanging out with these guys it's a
little pathetic wait what is that
supposed to mean
and speak for yourself so what about you
learn any new tricks in Australia
Haru glad you asked I'll show you what
they taught me how about a race what's
the race Haru did they just did just
think so the difference between the two
of us now it's like night and day all
right
go ahead and show this isn't a good idea
don't take your pants off oh you never
actually changed out of Liberty minds
think alike we have to stop them but do
we really just
[Music]
get ready there's no water yeah I know
that's why I was yelling for them to
stop what the hell oh yeah by the way
you losers come to dig this up our
trophy I don't need this thing anymore
you want it it's yours
Greene he's not at all like I remember I
don't know
no it really happened yeah maybe but it
doesn't make sense we never used to act
like that ah look-alike who just happens
to know who we are and challenge you to
a race fine ghost looks solid okay an
evil doppelganger hole like in the old
days it's a game that we played as kids
super fusion so I take it you know that
bunch of weirdos mm-hmm remember how I
can honest a Makoto Tachibana
Hazuki all of them used to be part of
the same Swim Club when they were little
kids it closed down recently but they're
still bound together by the girlish
sounding names why would you know who
they are it's a secret yeah but you do
kind of have something in common with
them because I mean you are a girl with
a boy's name are you that stupid just
because a place is abandoned doesn't
mean you couldn't have asked permission
what you guys did is still trespassing
yes sir sorry yeah me too where's non-si
already gone sir he left earlier of
course now now I think you've lectured
them enough let us remember the words of
Lee by one must never raise an empty
glass to the moon it's foolish not to
drink from the glass before you the
point of that saying is you only live
once so do what you want huh do we not
have the right to seek happiness as we
see fit after all what good is human
accomplishment if it fails to bring us
joy am i right I mean right
I mean Matsuoka green once you Olga or
are you ensure he goes to our school no
but if he's back from Australia there's
at least a chance he transferred here I
don't remember seeing him at the
assembly bingo
yeah wait no go Matsu oka sounds
familiar that's right this is Raines
little sister I remember now
Wow so go me buddy with Toby hi now too
huh tell comigo
it's actually pronounced Co but you I
mean you have the same name is he famous
warlord guys there Donna from the single
query yeah sure but it's but it's modern
times now and Co is how it's pronounced
so call me that you should respect the
girls wishes yes so moving right along
sorry but what were you doing at her
place I was going to ask him something
about my brother so didn't see a double
ganger rings really back from Australia
he came back last month he's going to
Samia canal it's a boarding school so he
hasn't technically been home home yet I
was just wondering if anyone else had
seen him oh he's going to some Massacre
the one with the ultra-powerful swim
team no come on music for a little bit
don't you want to say hello to Irene you
just saw him yesterday and here I was
thinking you jump at the chance to swim
in an actual pool samay saccas is indoor
but it doesn't sound like you're all
that interested
[Music]
nagamma
watch your speed slow it down you serine
anywhere not yet
might be out today hot stop taking your
clothes off well you're the one who
dragged me here to swim it I only came
to swim no hold on you're right but we
should probably wait till their
practices over so we can have the pool
to ourselves
you do realize that we're gonna be
trespassing right what did miss ah Makka
to say about never holding an empty
glass to the moon we've got to live our
lives you only live what is wrong with
you I still think this will get us in
trouble
just look how it homies
still moves like a dolphin hey let's
jump in and swim with him
are you nuts we're gonna be in so much
trouble if they find us the whole point
in coming was to find Reid let's do a
few laps first as long as we don't turn
on the lights no but he'll find us but
you don't have a swimsuit in a skinny
day
Makoto come here for a second Aaron say
if you think I'm getting
[Music]
you should have seen your face that's
right
laugh it up what the hell is this what
the hell are you bastards doing here
ring we were just looking for you
get out mean free
did you forget I told you I only swim
freestyle what's happening ro I'm
supposed to have three years left til
I'm normal but I guess it couldn't hurt
to wait a little longer
all of us if you showed me back then
that I wasn't supposed to forget it
seemed to be having a little trouble
remembering
[Music]
see what this is perfect your way just
so you know it'll be completely
different this time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she goes
[Music]
I am also
imagine
[Music]
so is there some specific reason not as
saying will only swim freestyle um Haru
looks like he doesn't want to answer
maybe you should take this win Makoto
okay should I use softer miso on my
grilled mackerel
can't decide so he was just thinking
about dinner the whole time next time
memories in the distance
look back there Hara pressure what about
the Munir sauce
[Music]
[Music]